Jag har hört det där förut, att det tar väldigt lång tid att ta fram krämer eller olika den sortens produkter.
Vad är det som är så jävla trögt?
Jag fattar inte.
Make Sweden Stronger Men är det så, nu gick vi in, du ska få berätta lite om det själv, men jag bara hoppar in här lite.
Det är rätt sjukt att ni, vad sa du, omsökt 160 miljoner.
Jag är ju Chernobyl-generationen, jag kan inte ta.
Du vet, vem är du typ?
Det låter inte så jävla verkligt.
Du har ren dess bra ord.
Ni har inga syra kolleger, ni bråkar aldrig, och det finns inga tulliga ögonblick.
Nu kanske jag får skit för detta, men jag håller med.
Men, vad brinner ni mest för?
Välkomna vid Svante Gabran från X-Lash till podden.
Det här är en företagsresa som jag är extremt fascinerad av.
X-Lash gjorde en ohyggligt snabb tillväxt från noll till hundra miljoner och sen fortsatte man växa efter det.
Sen hade man ett tungt eller kanske två tunga år och nu har man stabiliserat sig igen och nu verkar man ta fart igen.
Jag älskar den här sortens företagsresor som gör att det kiklas lite grann, som är lite berg-
och dalbarnig och som bara är fascinerande för alla av oss som tittar på från utsidan.
Så nu ska jag sluta prata.
Tjena, som inte välkommen till podden.
Tjena, en stort tack.
Jättekul att åka upp i ett samtal här idag.
Det ska bli roligt att snacka.
Jag kan ju också bara säga att vi sågs ju en gång på något sånt här e-handelsevent och vi tillhör ju på något sätt mot polerna inom e-handel.
Dels säljer vi till exempel väldigt tunga grejer och ni säljer betydligt lättare grejer.
Folk vet vilka ni är.
När jag sa till min flickvän att jag skulle intervjua Svante på Xlash så sa hon Ah, ah, har du deras reklam?
Funkar jävligt bra!
Jag fick upp deras Instagramgrej och jag gick in och jag köpte på tre minuter och köpte någon sån ögonfransgrej.
Det är ingen som vet vilka vi är om man inte är i gymbranschen.
Även där har ni lyckats väldigt väl.
Dessutom när vi satt på den här scenen och svarade på frågor så vill jag minnas att du pratade ju argumenterat, du hade dessutom siffror och kunde säga grejer.
Och mitt största argument var typ jag gillar inte stockholmare.
Det var jag minns från den.
Det är sent framträdande.
Skulle du säga att du är en professionell företagare?
Det får man väl ändå säga.
Nu har man jobbat med det så pass länge att man har ändå växt in i den kostymen får man inte säga.
Den kom ifrån ett entreprenörsled i vår uppstartad bolag och alltihopa.
Allt jämt med att man har växt mycket personal, större ansvar så behöver man ju ta några kliver professionella också.
Så det får man väl ändå kasta till sådant.
Nu har det liksom passerat.
Folk som inte känner till X-Lash men ni säljer, ni började väl med Ögonfrans Serum, men sen har det utvecklats lite grann men inom samma segment.
Ja, men nu när du har fått lite perspektiv på situationen, för ni hade ju en helt brutal tillväxt i början.
Jag tror att ni gick till 100 miljoner på två år.
Tre år, okej det får väl ändå räknas som rätt brutalt.
Vad var det som gjorde det?
Och vad innebar det?
Kan du inte ta oss med till den tiden?
Absolut, vi startade någonstans, egentligen så startades varumärket 2012, det har funnits sen tidigare, jag var med i den från starten, på den tiden var det inte lika etablerat, vi hade inte samma typ av bild vad vi skulle, det drevs lite med vänsterarmen på ett sätt.
Men sen 2018 när vi bestämde oss för att göra ett riktigt bolag av det här, och satsa på Beauty Generation som varumärkesägare av X-Lash, och faktiskt lägga all vår tid som ägare i bolaget, så gick det ganska snabbt från att gå från en liten omsättning till en ganska hög.
Det var en extrem resa, jag skulle också säga att E-handelsklimatet på den tiden var väldigt etablerad, och började växa, det var en stor hype just kring digitala brands som kom.
Och extra så var det ju den åldern när det gick snabbt, man kunde hitta en fin modell som fungerade, performance var lite mer utvecklat, influencer marketing var också en väldigt stor del av vår uppstart i resan.
Vi gick väldigt snabbt från 2018 till 2021 tror jag, till 100 miljoner.
Men varför gick ni så fort, det är inte så att ni är ensamma på marknaden om att vilja starta?
Jag tror att om man kollar på varumärket och produkten så hittade vi en väldigt tydlig nisch som vi hittade ett bra fast i.
Folk var intresserade av den här typen av produkten.
Vi lyckades väldigt bra med att komma ut med våra digitala marknadsföring också.
Det är även därifrån min bakgrund kommer också jobbat med digitala medier under väldigt lång tid.
Så vi lyckades skruva på en affärsmodell som var absolut digitalt tung, som gav effekt.
Då kan man väl säga kortfattat.
När du säger att din bakgrund är inom digital marknad, vad menar du då mer konkret?
Första bolaget och det första jag gjorde i mitt professionella liv var att driva en digital byrå som jobbade med Facebook marknadsföring, innan Facebook hade marknadsföring kan man säga.
På den tiden var det väldigt mycket applikationsbygge och skapa företagsprofiler.
Så det är egentligen där mitt första intresse inom digitala medier kommer ifrån.
Under den tiden fick man dels möta väldigt mycket bolag.
Man spanade väldigt mycket på de resor som var gamla tidens e-handlare, som nu finns idag också.
Man fick se mycket deras resor och inspirerades väldigt mycket av det.
Fick chans att testa mycket verktyg.
Early days av Facebook-annonseringen, Google-annonseringen.
På den tiden köpte man tidningsartiklar digitalt, vilket var jättespännande.
Det funkade bra på den tiden.
Jag har ändå varit med i medielandskapet under väldigt många år.
Det tror jag är en stark bidragande faktor till att vi kunde applicera det i ett varumärke också.
För mig är steget ganska långt.
Nu ser jag inte alla dig, men nu ser vi inte ut som en finnitåndåring.
När jag ser det här digital marknadsföring för femton år sedan, då ser jag att det är någon som sitter i ett mörkt rum och bara, hehehehe, titta.
Här kan jag få traction till.
Sen tänkte du, ögonfranserum, det känns som rätt produkt för mig att satsa på.
Hur gjordes den resan?
Det är en bra fråga och det är klart en koppling man behöver sätta ihop utifrån den beskrivningen också.
Med den digitala byrån som vi ändå fick, vi fick lite noise i branschpress och skapade lite intresse av själva det vi höll på med.
Det var ändå ganska unikt.
Det var inte så många som pysslade med den typen av marknadsföring.
Det var väldigt traditionellt när vi startade igång 2011.
Med det så fick vi kontakt med en fabrik som sa att vi har en produkt men vet inte hur vi ska göra av den.
Jag och Daniel som var väldigt tidiga i det här svåret sa att vi kan väl skapa ett varumärke och testa i handeln tänkte jag säga.
Men var det de som hörde av sig till er eller var det...
Jag är bara fascinerad.
Vi fick gemensam kontakt genom...
Jag skulle säga att det var från ett intressant team, vi har en produkt, vet inte hur vi ska göra med det.
Okej, vad roligt.
Och sen så byggde vi en resa på det.
Och det var även en del av vår partnerskap under väldigt många år också.
Så det var lite så själva idén startades, så hur vi grundade bolaget.
Och man frågar ju alltid, hur kom ni på det här?
Jag brukar alltid vända frågan, varför drivs vi av det här idag?
Vad är det som är så kul nu liksom?
Så jag tror också att det är en del i ens egna frågeställningar när man funderar på vad man pysslar med egentligen.
Och det är så länge sedan.
Det är nästan 15 år sedan vi började med den här företagaretsan.
Så det är många år bakom bälten.
Kan du komma ihåg ögonblicket när ni fick kontakt, och du och Daniel, när du och Daniel tittade på varandra och bara tänkte, ja, det här känns som en rimlig business för oss att testa.
Kan du minnas tanken bakom starten?
Ja, jag tror kanske inte att det var så uttalat hellre att nu kör vi, utan det var mer att låta oss testa, utan det var ju väldigt entreprenellt drivet från grund och start.
Vi är därifrån, vi är drivd i en gäng bolag, så jag tror att vi såg en möjlighet där, men vi kan nog göra någonting av det här, men vi vet inte om vi kan göra det.
Låt oss testa och se vad det kan ta vägen.
Det är kanske fördelen också när man är runt 20 år gammal att man har lite andra parametrar man kollar på i livet också.
Det var väldigt spännande tycker jag.
Produkten fungerade väldigt bra, det visste vi om med testen själva och många runt omkring oss.
Det fanns ändå ett tåtstoff i att man kan göra någonting av det.
Så det var lite svårt när det kom.
Sen hade ni ju, som många känner till, ni hade en helt bizarr resa uppåt som du berättade lite kort om, men sen hade ni ett eller ett par lite tyngre år och sen känns det liksom som att ni har hanterat det där.
Det känns som att ni har kommit tillbaka, ni hade någon artikel här i handel.se häromdagen där det stod lite om er framtida satsning.
Jag tror att de flesta företagare kan förstå att resor går svårt, man satsar på fel grejer eller man köper in vissa grejer.
Det jag är extremt fascinerad av är hur man mentalt ställer om i den resan och hur man kommer tillbaka på banan.
För att så som det brukar se ut, se ut som någon sorts upp-
och nedkurva.
Man går upp och kraschar det och lägger ner.
Det är ganska svårt att komma tillbaka.
Kan du förklara hur tankarna gick under tiden?
Vad ni fokuserade på för att komma tillbaka?
Hur ni har hanterat det?
Du får inte vara ödmjuk, inget sånt här.
Det var hårt arbete.
Ge mig lite grotta ner i det här.
Jag kan ge lite bakgrund till det också, så man förstår var vi kommer ifrån och hur vi hamnade på första början.
Som sagt så var vi inne på det första året.
Allt var väldigt startat och vi växte jättemycket.
Det var digitala tider och det funkar väldigt bra marknadsföringen.
Vi tog oss upp på en plattform som man är ändå, när man omsätter 100 miljoner, det är jättemycket i omsättning.
Lite stort bolag ändå, om man ändå säger.
Omsättningsmässigt, men fortfarande på en väldigt liten kostym.
Vi var åtta personer som drev det bolaget med ganska juniora utbildningar.
Och ni omsatte inte 100 miljoner, ni omsatte 160 miljoner någonting.
Det kom ut i snart.
Okej, okej.
Och då tänkte vi att det var ganska extrema tider också, när mycket handlade om tillväxt.
Det var ett stort fokus i branschen.
Alla skulle växa så mycket som det bara gick, och det kom bolag in som skulle ta nästa kliv, och massa pengar in i branschen och så vidare.
Och vi var såklart påverkade av det digitala klimatet.
E-handel var det hetaste man kunde jobba med i hela branschen.
Alla kategorier.
Och vi var såklart med i den sväng att man skulle följa med på den här efter att man kunde dubbla allt man gjorde.
Och det var ju sanningen också.
När man kommer från 0 till 30, 30 till 100, då har man ju den inblicken i sin verksamhet att vi kan lansera på alla marknader i världen om vi vill och göra samma sak.
Det är klart att det inte är sanningen.
Men det funkar inte så.
Ganska naivt företagande.
Och vi satsade ju all in och byggde en ganska stor staff.
Vi ville liksom använda sig till att vi kunde göra fler affärsmöjligheter med det vi satt på, jag tänkte.
Och göra bolaget lite mer professionellt än vad det var sen innan.
Så det var en ganska stor satsning med plattformbyten, ekonomisystem, lageruppsättningar.
Men vi investerade väldigt mycket i byggstensdelar, samtidigt som vi byggde en staf och hade ambition att växa extremt mycket.
Så det var ju en ganska rejäl satsning som krävs ganska mycket erfarenhet för att pull through och ganska mycket cash också för att klara av det.
Så vi var ganska tunga i den etappen, men samtidigt så mycket av det som vi byggde då har vi kvar idag, så vi är super tacksam för.
Men det tog oss upp på en nivå på nästan 170 miljoner, vilket var jättemycket.
Men vi backade på resultat det året och kände oss inte speciellt nöjda med hur det såg ut just då.
Och kände att vår färsmodell inte riktigt satt som den skulle.
Vi lyckades inte få den här effektiviteten i marknadsföringar som vi tidigare har haft och var tvungna att förändra hur vi arbetar.
Och där vid 2021-2022 årsskiftet så satte vi oss ner och sa att den här kundprofilen vi jobbar med inom business to business, hur funkar det mot vår egen e-handel?
Vi kan debalisera på egen affär.
Det finns ingen lönsamhet att driva det här på det sättet när vi vill driva en e-handelstung business.
Och det var en utmaning i sig att identifiera vad vi behöver göra för att ha en bättre affärsmodell rakt upp och ner.
Gå tillbaka till grundvalues någonstans i bolaget hur vi skulle driva affären.
Det hade gått väldigt snabbt innan.
Vi hade packat på oss massor av affärer utomlands och även i Sverige som kanske var ännu för mycket.
Där beslöt vi oss för att ta över modellen, ändra om strategin, jobba med en ny typ av businesspartner, B2B-partner, samtidigt som vi kunde driva vidare våra e-handel på ett bra sätt.
Vi tog några tuffa beslut för en del kunder.
Och såklart, under den här tiden, man satt ju på ganska mycket lager också som vi var tvungna att vara på utmarknad och så vidare.
Så de besluten vi tog påverkade ekonomin väldigt tungt, men någonstans ändå gav oss ett utrymme att kunna ta oss vidare till en bättre affärsmodell som är i dag.
Du har ju ett långt svar på den här frågan.
Nej, nej, nej och vi är ju inte ens halvvägs in i det, men vi vet fortfarande hur ni ställde om tankarna och hur ni påverkas.
Kör på du, pratar du?
Från beslut om att ta det här resktivet till att man kom in i en vägg där det var negativa siffror och kände att det håller inte.
Vi kan inte överleva vårt bolag om vi inte puttar in massa pengar i det.
Så var vi tvungna att ta de här tuffa besluten.
Det betyder också att bygga om hela personals styrka.
Det är lite mindre.
Det är nog de värsta besluten man tagit i sitt liv.
Att vi behöver gå in i ett varselprocess för att minska vår styrka.
Som företagsledare är det inte roligt på något plan alls.
Och framförallt inte som en relativt junior företagsledare som man ändå får säga att man kanske var på den tiden och fortfarande är i viss mån.
Men med lite erfarenheter så var det ett jättetrufft steg att ta och minska sin styrka.
Så det var tufft helt klart.
Men det var väldigt nödvändigt och vi jobbade väldigt day by day drivet.
Det var nästa dags beslut som påverkade helheten.
Så ganska primitivt arbetet vilket är positivt, det är ju månt och mycket för att man agerar väldigt mycket på de bränder man ser och de actions man måste ta.
Det blir väldigt taskdrivet i arbetssättet.
Men det skapar också något i människan som man vill ta sig vidare och klara av den här lilla trösken hela tiden.
Jag tror framför allt som förut tagit också i det en ganska stor styrka att jobba i motvind eller vad man säger, när det är tufft.
Man blir väldigt orienterad på det som behövs.
Det tror jag ändå var en styrka att vi orkade jobba så, höll i det och det har nästan tagit två år till att komma tillbaka till en sund affärsmodell där vi känner oss att nu kan vi börja hitta vägar framåt igen.
Så under tiden de här åren, 2022, 2023, använder hela 2024 också har vi fokuserat jättemycket på.
Vilka affärspartner jobbar vi med?
Hur ska vi jobba ner i handel?
Ekonomistyrningen har varit supercentral, varumärkesfokuserat har varit en riktig cornerstone också.
Att vi vill sätta hela varumärkesprofilen på ett modernt och ett sätt vi vill jobba på med vårt community, kundgrupp och så vidare.
Men även en stor utveckling i produktportfölj också för att kunna bli lite bredare i det vi arbetar med.
Så det har varit en rejäl resa att ta sig i tuff ekonomi samtidigt som man gör en stor redesigning och brandarbete.
Men också nödvändigt för att skapa det här nya varumärket som man kommer ut med på andra sidan.
Det är väl lite där vi är idag kan man säga.
Tog ditt ego stryk under den här perioden?
Kan du uppleva att du blev tvingad att bli...
När man skaffar barn till exempel, då tar ego ett stryk för man inser att jag tänkte att jag skulle vara den här sortens person.
Jag skulle ta alla fighte på rätt sätt, uppfostra så här och så bara nej jag kompromissar på allt.
Samma sak i detta kunde du tänka att du hade kanske någon...
För du är väl 35 idag då, då måste du ha varit typ 30 när det här verkligen gick.
Jag hade i alla fall, om jag gick igenom den resan när jag var 30 så hade jag känt att jag var liksom Gud.
Jag kunde göra vad jag ville och sen va fan, jag kunde inte öppna alla marknader på samma gång.
Fan jag har tänkt fel i mitt tankesätt.
Och då, jag är bara fascinerad av hur man klarar av den.
Liksom, att komma tillbaka från den.
Eller upplevde du inte så?
Var det mer så här, jag ska hantera ett problem?
Ja men jag tror att man landar i den sitse att man verkligen bara vill hantera det som behövs hanteras.
Du sitter ju också i princip i dagar från att pengarna tar slut.
Då behöver man bara hantera det man måste hantera.
Fokus var ju väldigt mycket på att bara se till att vi tar de beslut som påverkar det positiva kortsiktigt.
Så jag tror att absolut att kanske ens bild om bolaget kanske tog lite stryk under den perioden.
Jag tror inte så mycket ego, utan det blir nog snarare fokus på att lösa problemen som vi är inne på.
Så varumärket eller bolagets bilden fick absolut en törn i.
Man trodde att man kunde göra precis så om man växer på alla planer.
Men också är jag otroligt tacksam för den här perioden.
Det är den bästa läxan och resan man kan lära sig att gå igenom ett sådant här tufft stålbad.
För att man blir ganska ödmjuk till att bara driva affär innebär också.
Så det är ju inte bara negativt att passera igenom de här tuffa åren.
Man plockar på sig ganska bra erfarenheter som man kan använda sig av i exempel nu eller under tid.
Som man har lite större respekt för.
Hur planerar vi en resa till nästa gång?
Så det skulle jag säga att vi har bedrugit med sig väldigt mycket gott från den här perioden som har varit otroligt tung.
Det är inte all bad.
Om tio år är det en fantastisk ryggsäck att ha och veta vad det är viktiga att fokusera på.
Det är grymma erfarenheter.
Kunde du vakna upp ibland och bara känna att det var länge sedan vi fokuserade på produkter?
Det är väldigt mycket processer och arbete.
Jag tror på vår del så har vi alltid haft produkt väldigt centralt i verksamheten.
Inom den här branschen som vi jobbar i tar det väldigt lång tid att ta fram produkt.
I våra produktcyklar så jobbar vi i princip 18 månader från vid det till färdig på marknad.
Det är en väldigt lång planering.
Då, med tanke på att vi haft en tuff tid bakom oss och vi har lanserat 27 produkter så har vi jobbat på de här senast nästan ett och ett halvt år innan.
Det har ändå varit väldigt centralt.
Det var en del av varumärkesresan också att bädda sortiment.
Vi har under tiden satsat väldigt mycket på vår R&D-avdelning och verkligen försökt att göra så bra saker som möjligt för marknaden så att vi kan ta kliv i varumärket också.
Så det är väl svar på den frågan om man säger så.
Vi fokuserar extremt mycket på produktivbolagen.
Jag har hört det där förut att det tar väldigt lång tid att ta fram krämer eller olika den sortens produkter.
Vad är det som är så jävla trögt?
Jag fattar inte.
Kan man inte bara stå bredvid någon som blandar?
Vad är det som drar ut på tiden?
Vad är det enskilt största, krångliga?
Om man kollar på vår process och allt börjar någonstans i ett konceptstadie där man ser att den här typen av konceptprodukter vill vi utforska och utveckla.
Bara den delen tar lite tid att identifiera vad som passar inom varumärket, vad som passar i vårt portfölj och sen så komma ner till marginalförhandlingar när man sätter upp alla komponenter i en produkt.
Det tar också en liten period att komma överens med leverantörerna och de man producerar med.
I vårt fall, eller inom beauty-överlag, så är det väldigt långa testningsperioder av varje produkt.
Vi får inte släppa en produkt på marknaden som inte har gått igenom, till exempel sex månaders testperioder av olika mikrobiologiska tester och liknande.
Så det finns ganska mycket regleringar kring vad som får och inte får.
Testas allting även om det är standardiserade innehåll?
Det är det som är skillnaden också.
Om du har en off-the-shelf-produkt så kan det gå mycket snabbare, men då har du ingen påverkan på produkten, då sätter du egentligen bara din layman på den.
Det är klart att man kan jobba så, det funkar jättebra för väldigt många, men från våra perspektiv så har vi ändå lagt ganska mycket egna krav på produkter när vi tar fram dem och då tar det längre tid kast.
Så det är väl olika arbetssätt.
Det hoppar vi över.
Får jag fråga om Daniel, din kollega, han har ju hängt med från start.
Kan du inte prata lite om er dynamik för att jag gissar att ni fortfarande är vänner.
Det finns ju ganska många polare som har drivit bolag ihop och så blir man kanske inte polare någon gång för att man har lite olika syn.
Hur har ni delat upp er jobbet och hur ni jobbar och vem som ska ta tag i vad och hela det här.
Kan du inte prata lite om er dynamik?
Jag tror att vi var väldigt tydliga och tidiga med att definiera vem gör vad i bolaget och det var också lite förutsättningar för att kunna driva en vd-roll som jag ännu besitter idag är att kunna ha en mandat över det operationella och det som sker på kontor.
Det är en superviktig del för min egen del att verkligen kunna styra på det sättet som jag vill.
Vi pratade igenom det och vi följde väl båda i att det passar ganska bra i våra ambitioner också och vad vi ska arbeta med.
Jag tror att det har varit en väldigt god förutsättning för att vi ska kunna hålla en jättebra relation idag också.
Sedan sitter jag och Daniel och pratar dagligen om utmaningar, idéer och projekt som man skulle kunna driva.
Men det är också så här när man sitter i en organisation jämfört med vad man kanske har på ett idénsstadie.
Det är ju väldigt stor skillnad på att man vet hur lång tid saker tar.
Så man behöver ju ha en respekt för den processen mellan oss två också.
Men jag tycker att vi ändå har hittat ett bra samarbete.
Vi har jobbat tillsammans i nästan över tio år.
Så det är väldigt lång tid vi har gått igenom.
Det är tuffa tid tillsammans, bra tid tillsammans.
Och man lär sig väldigt mycket av det också.
Och så säger Daniel, vi har också en gäng andra bolag som har gått i sidan om X-Lars projektet i år.
Så det har verkligen varit händerfulla på olika delar av världen.
Så vi har också kunnat packa in väldigt mycket information från de olika resorna vi har gjort för att kunna idéer skapa och sätta en bra strategi tillsammans.
Men är det det som är det viktiga?
Att man styr upp, det här är din roll, det här är min roll.
Är det enskilt viktigaste?
Det kan vi bara prata för oss.
För oss har det funkat väldigt bra tycker jag.
Jag tror att det är lätt att man drar på varandra på fötterna och har olika idéer och det kan bli konflikter väldigt snabbt om man inte har en väldigt tydlig, om en gränsdragning från vad ens jobb innebär.
Så jag tror det är väldigt viktigt att man har den dialogen väldigt tidigt.
För det kan ju gå väldigt snabbt, det kan springa iväg eller det kan hända tuffa saker så man behöver ena sådant.
Någonstans där behöver man ha en god acceptans till varandras positioner, roller och idéer på ett sätt.
Sen så klart att man behöver bolla det tillsammans med varandra hela tiden också, självklart.
Men jag tror att det är en viktig förutsättning helt klart att prata om det i ett tidigt stadio.
Det är framförallt till alla nya bolag som startas med vänner som har gått ihop eller liknande.
Det är ett tips.
Prata igenom när ni väl börjar sätta roller, för det blir också en sak när man får in personal i bolaget och andra ansvar man har på det.
Det tror jag är viktigt för oss också.
Någonstans är min position ytterst personalansvarig som vd och då behöver man se till att man har den strukturen uppsatt.
Det blir mitt ansvar att äga också.
Nu vill jag prata svenskt produktion.
Är det?
Jag gissar att du går igång på det lika mycket som jag gör, för annars hade ni inte satt upp det här i Sverige och investerat i det.
Kan du inte prata lite grann om dels varför ni tog ämnet i Sverige, dels fördelarna med det och dels nackdelarna med det.
Och inom just det här segmentet som vi pratade om också.
För om jag tar hem produktion till Sverige, då är det liksom borra i en stålgrej.
Det är ju inte så omgärdat av krångel.
Jag gissar att ditt är lite mer omgärdat av krångel.
Både och.
Jag ska säga att vi har ju alltid producerat våra serum i Europa.
Det har ändå varit en superviksidél för oss.
Vi hade produktion i Spanien innan och det var en ganska stor producent som producerade väldigt många olika typer av beautyprodukter.
Det var ett bra samarbete men vi märkte också att det fanns distans till hur mycket vi kan påverka och inte under den här processen.
Så beslut av att ta hem våra serum var att vi hade en affärsbekant som drev ett labbmiljö nere i Lund som också hade produktion av andra typer av produkter men inte inom vår kosmetiska nisch.
När vi pratade igenom produktionen och vad vi hade för facilitet och möjligheter så var vi ganska snabbt att vi kan faktiskt göra en liknande setup på svensk mark på ett ganska smidigt sätt också.
Så tillsammans med dem valde vi ut och handlade in maskinpark som vi var tvungna att ha för att kunna ha den typen av produktion.
Sen så är det klart det är ganska tuffa regler och krav på att ta svensk produktion inom den här branschen också.
Så det är ganska, ja men vi måste arbeta efter en viss ISO-standard som är regleringsverket för att kunna producera kosmetiska hudnära produkter.
Och de har tidigare jobbat med medicinsk produktion så det passade väldigt bra in i vår miljö på det sättet.
Så faciliteten fanns, kunskapen fanns, R&D-kompetensen fanns även hos vår labbpartner för att kunna göra den blandning som behövs och den testprocessen som behövs också.
Det är som sagt varje batch vi släpper ut, om vi nu pratar industritermer här, måste vi gå igenom tester på för att det ska kunna släppas på marknaden.
Det behöver loggas i en viss typ av process ifall ett läkemedelsverk eller liknande skulle komma och göra stickprover på produktionen.
Så det är superviktigt att man har den säkerhetsaspekten klar innan man går in i en sån produktion inom vår bransch också.
På så sätt finns det ganska mycket mallar man behöver följa.
Det är punkt och pricka.
Det har varit superviktigt i just den svenska hemtagningen.
Fördelar med det är att vi kan på dagen åka dit och besöka dem.
Vilket är jättebra.
Vi kan prata om utmaningar i allt från paketeringsprocess till nya R&D-koncept och liknande som vi behöver arbeta fram.
Det går väldigt snabbt.
Där kan vi ha en annan typ av dialog med den här parten som vi har idag än tidigare.
Det tycker jag är en väldigt stor fördel.
Nackdelsmässigt, ja.
Sverige ligger lite oft på kartan, det kan man ju säga.
Det har varit lite utmaningar ibland i logistiken, men det har ändå funkat, sådana saker.
Jag skulle säga att det är ändå otroligt positivt till att kunna ta hem en produktion.
Det är en stark satsning man har gjort tycker jag ändå.
Är det en satsning mer gjord för er och era arbetssätt och er filosofi än för kunden?
Bryr sig kunden om, ifall det är tillverkat i Sverige eller inte?
På riktigt menar jag.
Man vill ju tro det tänkte jag säga, och det hoppas man verkligen.
Vi kommunicerar det ganska mycket i våra kommunikationer, vi lade tag i marknadsföring och PDPR på hemsida och till våra partners, business to business.
Det ses ju absolut som en stabilitet och en trygghet i att ha en svensk produktion, det tycker jag absolut.
Det finns ett kvalitetsstämpelvärde i det.
Och framförallt är det en bransch där mycket kommer från Kina, man har inte full dokumentation på allt det, så för oss är det absolut en kvalitetsstämpel som vi anser är viktig.
Och jag tror att även våra partners och kunder ser det också.
Om man kollar varumärkets där som det har funnits så pass länge, så finns det ändå en trovärdighet i det.
Och jag tror absolut att vårt svenska heritage är en del av den trovärdigheten i varumärketsbyggnaden.
Kan vi inte fastna där lite i er varumärke?
För att för mig då som oinsatt så är det väl kläder kanske och det här, vad kallar ni?
Beautysegmentet kanske, jag vet inte vad jag kallar det här som det råkar.
För mig framstår det som två helt hopplösa branscher.
För att det finns så många varumärken, det finns, när man säger influencer så finns det liksom, det är där 90 procent av alla influencers är.
Så för mig är det liksom, jag förstår inte hur man sticker ut, jag förstår inte hur man bygger unikitet, jag tycker att allting känns likadant.
Som sagt jag kan ingenting av detta men liksom, jag tycker att det verkar rätt krångligt.
Kan du ta mig igenom hur man sticker ut?
Och inte bara hur man bygger en snabb trend på TikTok som är populärt i ett halvår, utan nu har ni ändå funnits x antal år och sånt på rätt höga nivåer under x antal år.
Hur skapar man det där?
Någonstans man vill börja med att produkten behöver leverera ett resultat.
Det är väl någonstans det som gör att man har en konsistens i sin produkt också.
Att man har ett product promise och varumärket promise som är att vi levererar på det vi säger.
Det är nog en jätteviktig del.
Det är även del av våra core values, att ha resultat och effekt som en viktig cornerstone i det vi bryr oss med.
Jag vill bara fråga, i eget segment, om vi, typ det enda jag förstår är ögonfrans grej.
Man vill att de ska se längre ut, säger jag då.
Det finns väl ganska många produkter som gör det där, men är ni då en av de bästa inom detta?
Är det så om man mäter det?
Ja, om man kan säga att de är en av de bästa eller inte, vårt varumärke och våra produkter levererar på det vi säger.
Det är det viktigaste med att ta ifrån det.
Det finns otroligt mycket som du är inne på också, det finns produktioner som kommer utifrån och inifrån och allt möjligt.
Det är verkligen ett snåligt träsk för att skapa en trovärdighet i produkten.
Så från vår sida har det varit väldigt mycket att trycka på de värdena som ändå vi tycker är viktiga.
Vi har resultat, vi har effektprodukter, det är någonting som vi står för, det är någonting vi utvecklar för hela tiden.
Vi jobbar jättemycket med community driven marknadsföring och väver in våra kunder väldigt mycket i tjänsterna, varumärket vilket är superviktigt för oss.
Det är någonting som vi trycker på för att skapa en gemensamhet i varumärket Xlash.
Det tror jag är väldigt viktigt inom beautybranschen, framförallt för att sticka ut.
Man ska förklara det på ett bra sätt men vi tappar ihåg mig förut.
Du kan förklara det på ett halvbra sätt, för det är ändå bättre än vad jag kan förklara det så att...
Det viktiga med att skapa community i den här branschen är att...
Som sagt, communitydelen i skönhetsbranschen är jätteviktig för att man får en lite av en igenkänningsfaktor från nära och kära, de man känner och träffar.
Word of mouth marknadsföringen är extremt viktig.
För oss handlar det väldigt mycket om att fokusera på att vi har våra kunder som centrala i vår kommunikation och de jobbar som spokesperson för varumärket på ett bra sätt.
Vi måste skapa en miljö där de trivs och vill vara en del av vårt varumärke.
Jag tror att det är en jätteviktig del och jag arbetar med de värdena på ett bra sätt så att man skapar en inspirerande miljö, en informativ miljö.
Man skickar ut väldigt mycket information, inte bara om det här är produkten som gör det, utan även inspirationsvideor, artiklar och liknande.
Det är en superviktig drivare i vår bransch skulle jag säga.
Det finns jättemycket produkter, det är ett väldigt snåligt restdel verkligen.
Jag tror att skapa känslan av att man är del av varumärket och få se helheten av det är en stark faktor helt klart.
Har ni bestämt en målgrupp ni vill ha eller en viss kund eller blev det den kunden när ni skapade produkterna?
Jag tror inte att vi har definierat så hårt.
Vi har alltid sagt att vi vill vara breda i produktmixen mot målgruppen.
Det har ändå varit en viktig del.
Sen jobbar vi absolut med ett tagligt personas i vår kommunikationsguideline och liknande.
Det är absolut något som vi arbetar efter när vi pratar om kommunikationsuttrycken.
Men om man kollar på vår demografiska karta så är det jättespännande att vi har kunder i allt från 20 upp till 65 plus.
Det är en väldigt stor bredd på vilka som använder produkt.
Det tror jag också är för att vi riktar varumärket ganska brett.
Vi använder väldigt mycket olika personer i vår kommunikation och försöker lyfta stories från olika narrativ.
Det tror jag är en väldigt viktig del för vårt varumärke, att vi har den bredden i kommunikation.
Produkten funkar ju lika bra för en ung person som en äldre person.
Har ni vissa kunder som ni inte vill ha som skulle förstöra varumärket?
Nej men i klass kan man väl säga att allt för unga personer är ingenting som vi kan ha.
Vi får inte rikt oss för ungt i marknadsföringen, det är superviktigt.
Där är TikTok en jätte utmanande faktor.
Vi arbetar ju super mycket på TikTok, väldigt organiskt men försöker hålla en väldigt bra standard på ålder i samarbeten och så vidare.
Det är jätteviktigt för oss att vi inte går för ungt.
Det där försöker vi hålla en bra gräns.
Vem är det som sätter er språk?
Är det du som är ansvarig för det här eller vad vi vill förmedla för känsla?
Vem är den personen eller den gruppen?
Vi har jobbat jättemycket med varumärketsbilden över de senaste åren.
Senast i tre till fyra åren har vi gjort ett jättestort förändringsarbete i vår kommunikation och vi har ett team som jobbar med det inhouse.
Det är en grupp av fyra av fem personer och sen så jobbar vi jättemycket med er handelsteamet och produktteamet och business to business och så vidare för att få in information från de olika avdelningarna.
Även kunstnäst är väldigt centrala i den delen också.
Det är ett marknadsteam mer eller mindre.
Så vi har väl en inhouse byrå kan man säga.
Så vi har rätt för vårt varumärke på det sättet, fast anställda dem.
Är de själva som er målgrupp eller är de analyser från utsidan?
Är det bara intresserade av hur man gör?
Jo men det tycker jag ändå.
Jag tycker absolut att de representerar varumärket utifrån sina personligheter också.
Och ni har sagt att de är väldigt olika som personligheter också, vilket är positivt tycker jag.
Det är väldigt många olika infallsvinklar när vi pratar om varumärket.
Och det är superviktigt.
Vi kan inte ha en alltför generisk syn på vårt brand, utan vi behöver ha väldigt många utomstående perspektiv i det också.
Så vi försöker verkligen jobba med kundundersökningar, prata väldigt mycket med spokesperson i branschen, experter inom branschen också för att se vad de ser och hur de uppfattar ett varumärke.
Så för oss är det superviktigt att ta in så mycket information som möjligt och skapa en bild utifrån våran varumärkesbild därifrån.
När det gäller ett varumärke, eller ett företag som er då, som kanske säljer mot rätt stor grupp och som jobbar i många olika företag eller på olika länder och på olika sätt, och nu är ni ju ändå ett gäng anställda.
Hur gör man för att bibehålla fokus i det där?
Hur bygger du liksom ett bolag där ni fattar vad ni ska göra, där alla har koll?
I vår strategiarbete som vi brukar sätta igång någonstans i början av Q4 är att identifiera var vi har möjligheterna, var ser vi funkar, vad behöver vi göra bättre, vilka delar behöver vi fokusera på.
Man börjar som alltid med en stor mind map med massa idéer och sen försöker man trappa ner det till vad som är nyckel för businessen.
Där har vår ekonomiavdelning en stor påverkan också på att kolla rent finansiellt vad är viktigt att vi fokuserar på och inte tappar fokus på.
Jag tror att det handlar mycket mer om att sätta ett par få initiativ och arbeta stenhårt mot dem än att vara allt för idéer, idéer spridda.
Om man kollar på våra mål framåt nu så handlar det om en nordisk fokus är jätteviktigt.
Vi vill etablera den här marknaden som vi är på ännu tydligare.
Det är en jätteviktig del för oss.
Det kan man bryta ut i tusen små tasks också.
Finland är en del, Danmark är en del, Norge är en del, Sverige ska vi bibehålla på det här sättet och så vidare.
Det är superviktigt att man verkligen har de här high level målen som är fortfarande ganska precisa och specifika.
Men sen bryter ner dem i mindre uppgifter på det, mindre målbilder.
Så det är väl ett superertilt arbetssätt som vi arbetar efter.
Därefter får ju varje avdelning också forma sina mål utifrån de stora målen som man arbetar mot.
Sen så arbetssättmässigt så jobbar vi jättemycket med project management system, alltså Asana i vårt fall, som vi har lagt extremt mycket tid på för att få en struktur som funkar.
Så strukturellt sett så är det väldigt, vi följer mer eller mindre day-to-day som går mot de målen vi har sett upp för året.
Det är ju en jätteviktig del.
Både finansiella mål, men också mot mer projektmål som vi driver.
Hur delaktig.
Kort förklarat.
Nej, det är skitbra.
Jag är väldigt fascinerad av detta för att vi har ju inget sånt där.
Det är sådana här grejer som får mig att känna att fan vilken jävla pajas avdelning vi är.
Men sitter ni hela företaget där ändå och bara går igenom det här och handuppräckningar?
Jag håller inte med om den där, kan vi fylla där?
Vi försöker köra workshops iallafall kvartalsvis.
Vi lyckas inte alltid men vi har ambitioner att göra det.
Där man vitt och brett från olika hållepositioner får lägga sina mind maps och post-it-lappar på idéer och tankar och sånt här ser vi.
Vad kan vi göra med det?
Det är superviktigt.
Sen har vi ett kommersiellt team som sitter i princip varje vecka och varannan vecka lite större möten för att diskutera och arbeta ut uppgifter mot de här målsättningarna också.
Vi följer det löpande över hela året.
Det är en supercentral del i vårt arbetssätt.
Det rekommenderar jag också.
Vem bestämde att ni skulle börja jobba så?
Är det du som har jobbat så?
Ja, jag tror att vi som ledningsgrupp identifierade det väldigt tidigt.
Vi behöver ha en processstyrning i vissa delar.
Det här kan vara superavskräckande att höra också att det blir för mycket micro på ett sätt, men jag tror att när man får igång en sån här struktur och det tar tid att nötade så är det ganska befiend för att man kan se progressen väldigt tydligt.
Framför allt när man lirar mot resultat ser man att det gav effekt av att vi skulle göra tio TikToks om det här ämnet.
Det är skalade mot målet, vilket är jättehäftigt att se.
Och det blir också en typ av historiebok man bygger när man jobbar på det här sättet.
Man får med sig väldigt mycket insikter som man kan plocka med sig inför kommande planeringar och liknande.
Men sen lägger vi ut jättemycket ansvar i teamet att forma sina planer utifrån de här målsättningarna också.
Såklart itererar vi dem och har en process där vi går igenom och matchar det här mot de här initiativen, funkar det mot den här avdelningen.
Vi driver ju ändå en ganska bred affär med tanke på att vi har sex försäljningsled som vi arbetar med som ska funka med hela den kommersiella agendan.
Så det är väldigt mycket att hålla koll på i form av e-handel är ju bara komplex till sig och sen så har man business to business-delen som är wholesale-verksamhet, distributionsverksamhet, salongsverksamhet, travel retail som vi också är inne i och nu nosar vi ett marketplace.
Så det är många delar och specialister på som vi behöver hantera.
Jag tror att det är en förutsättning för att vi ska klara av att hantera det stora ekosystemet i ett ganska litet bolag.
När ni jobbar på de här olika affärsbenen eller försäljningskanalerna, hur synkar ni dem?
Jag hade personligen tyckt att det var lite läskigt att släppa kontrollen över till exempel prissättning eller vem som säljer vad eller vilka de samarbetar med eller vad de gör.
Hur väger ni för-
och nackdelar där?
Om man kollar på retail som vi jobbar väldigt mycket med, det var som jag berättade tidigare också att vi gjorde en stor förändring i vår affärsmodell där vi valde ut ett gäng partners som är ganska få men stora, som driver butiksverksamhet som är också en viktig del för oss.
Vi vill finnas i handen i ett antal dörrar är en viktig del som vi kollar på väldigt mycket.
Deras planering är helt annorlunda jämfört med den nya handelsplaneringen, men om vi pratar om retailpartner så har de marknadsprogrammet satt för 2026 nu typ.
Så vi styr planerar utifrån deras kalendrar in i våra kalendrar.
Det är ingen utmaning när man har en liten snabb fotade e-handel.
Men det är också där våra system kommer in, att vi lägger verkligen marknadskartor hela året och jobbar ut efter det.
Vilka projekt kan vi driva närvaro, hur?
Och sen matchar man det mot likviditetsanalyserna som visar kan vi göra de här grejerna om vi vill göra en stor 360-satsning, kan vi göra det om vi har mycket inköp under den här perioden.
Så det är ju en extremt viktig del att man planerar genom hela bolaget.
Jag tycker ändå att den strukturen vi sätter upp funkar relativt bra för att ha den översikten vi kollar på.
Nu sövade jag bort från frågan kanske.
Det gör ingenting.
Kan du ibland bara känna att fan vad mycket skönare det hade varit att bara ha en egen e-handel omsättna 20 miljoner V2-persson som bara sitter och rullar detta?
Nej, min ambition med varumärket är...
Jag trodde inte att du skulle säga ja.
Nej, men absolut ambitionen med det här varumärket är att kunna ta det.
Det har alltid varit det.
Jag tycker att vi satt ihop våra målsättningar från 2018 när vi startade upp Beauty, att vi ska kunna göra det här till en riktig, stor Beauty aktör.
Det har varit en målsättning helt klart.
Världen blir starka vägen kör liksom.
Det har verkligen varit en målsättning.
Vi har alltid haft ett globalt mindset och försökt att få ut produkter i världen också.
Vi jobbar ibland med distributörer i Singapore, Taiwan, Spanien, i Swage.
Så vi har ganska bred global försäljning också.
Fast där vi jobbar med distributörer som vi har jobbat med.
Ja men goda partnerskapningar.
Så nej, vi är absolut inte skalanigare.
Snarare jobba ännu mer professionellt och skala upp det.
Och verkligen försöka etablera sig som en beauty varumärke.
Skandinavisk beauty, det vill vi göra.
Nordiskt.
Men låt oss säga, du pratade förut om att ni gjorde en hel del satsningar och ni har satt ganska många block på plats och processer och liknande.
Vad är den stora utmaningen nu framåt?
Eller vad är nästa grej i skalan?
Vad jobbar ni med de närmsta fem åren?
Det har varit tuffa ekonomiska tider i Sverige och i världen.
Man har verkligen varit tvungna att tänka sig efter vad man kan göra och vilka förutsättningar man har.
Förhoppningsvis har vi kanske stabila ekonomiskt läge framåt.
Det vet man aldrig om man får jobba med det ändå.
Som jag nämnde innan så är det en väldigt tydlig nordisk fokus att det blir den marknaden som en key market i vår modell.
Det är nummer ett steget och det kommer nog att ta de åren.
Jag tror inte att det finns någon snabb spooling som man kan trycka på.
Det är ett väldigt fylligt fokus på att vi ska etablera oss lika mycket som i Sverige på andra marknader i Norden.
Så det är ett absolut första steg.
Sen kollar man rent produktmässigt så kommer vi fortsätta att utveckla vår produktportfölj och bredda varumärket inom nischen, ögon och bryn, och fransar såklart.
Så det är också en jätteviktig strategisk satsning vi gör inom det segmentet.
Tydligare position för varumärket, tydligare position kopplat till produktstrategi och även det erbjudandet som varumärket står för.
Så den är jätteviktig att fortsätta satsa på.
Vi har absolut några små härliga initiativ.
Travel retail är en sån sak som vi har satt ganska mycket på senaste två åren och börjar få lite traction på.
Det tar också väldigt lång tid i de processerna.
Så det är ett pågående arbete att etablera en annan typ av försäljningskanal.
Vad är det mer vi gör?
Om man kollar på fem års sikt så har vi etablerat X-Lars ännu starkare i Norden.
Det är första steget.
Sen vill vi absolut börja spana på en expansionsmarknad också som är utanför Norden.
Men det är inte riktigt definierat ännu vart vi ska någonstans.
Men vi hade gärna tagit tid utomlands också för att få en mer etablering på en ny marknad.
Idag säljer vi som sagt brett, men jag skulle verkligen vilja ta nästa klid och etablera en till marknad utanför Nordens gränser, absolut.
Vad är det svåra med att växa om man skulle säga så?
Är det att det tar lång tid att få fram produkter eller är det svårt att etablera nya marknader eller är det att det kostar väldigt mycket pengar att etablera?
Vad är de stora hindren?
Jag tror absolut att lokalanpassningen är en jätteviktig del att kolla på.
Vi har gjort satsningar förut där vi inte varit tidigt lokalanpassade och bränt oss om vi har haft dåliga fraktmöjligheter i Holland.
Vi kan bränna en marknad.
Alltså sådana saker.
Jag tror att det är en viktig del att gå igenom och det kanske låter lite tråkigt, men det är ändå en viktig del att man sätter de här fundamentala delarna.
Att betala möjligheterna ska funka.
Kundtjänsten måste vara precis.
Det måste vara leveransmetoder som en holländska aktör i Holland.
Och så vidare.
Så det är nog väldigt viktiga delar.
Sedan så är det absolut kostsamt att ta nya marknader.
Det kan man ju säga på en gång.
Man behöver göra en rejäl satsning också om man vill etablera varumärket.
Så det tror jag är absolut en sådan sak som man behöver se över och hitta en modell kring en tydlig go-to-market-strategi.
För när man väl gör det.
Och framförallt om man ska bli bestående på en marknad.
Jag tror det är det viktiga också.
Du kan säkert göra små satsningar som flyger lite här och där och funkar ganska bra.
Men ska du etablera ett varumärke och som verkligen går in så finns det så många olika värden man behöver bygga på och sätta som ska skapa en typ av consistency som håller över tid.
För det är ju också då man kan bära frukten av den satsningen också.
Oftast gör man inte det år ett när man går in på en ny marknad.
Det tror jag är en jätteviktig del att ta med sig när man kollar på expansion överlag.
Vad är den långsiktiga planen här?
Jag kan tycka att i 99,9% så skiljer vi oss om i allting här företagsmässigt.
Men jag tycker att den grejen som jag hör, som vi är mest lika på är att på något sätt så vill vi båda ha liksom grundprodukten och vara grundobjektet som folk jämför vår business mot.
För när du pratar om produkter så är det så här att folk ska veta att det funkar.
Eller när vi går in på en marknad, vi ska inte in där och där, utan vi ska göra det här långsiktigt.
Vad ska vara där, permanenta.
Och jag har lite samma syn.
Även fast jag tänker mycket olika kring annat så är det den här att, om man ska köpa någonting inom det här segmentet, jag vill ha någonting som funkar.
Jag går till dem för jag vet att det funkar.
Man är liksom fallat tillbaka på bolaget på något sätt.
För jag kan bara känna den känslan.
Det är så man jobbar på något sätt.
Att processerna finns alltid där.
Allting ska bara funka hela tiden.
Inklusive produkten då eller det man säger.
Man får inte lova för mycket men man lovar så att folk vet att det funkar.
That's it.
Jag ska inte hålla dig ännu mer.
Jag är extremt fascinerad av er business.
Jag ser verkligen fram emot att följa den här resan framöver.
Jag hoppas att vi från sidlinjen får heja på.
Stort tack för att du tog dig tid att vara med i podden.
Tack själv, jättekul att ha med.
Jag hoppas man har jätte goda insikter, idéer och tankar till andra företag därute också.
För om jag tar hem produktion till Sverige, då är det liksom borra i en stål-grej.
Det är ju inte så omgärdat av krångel.